ja und diese Nachricht erreicht uns
gerade eben aus Kiew es gab einen
Raketenangriff auf den Fernsehturm der
Hauptstadt russische Streitkräfte also
beschießen nach Angaben des ukrainischen
Innenministeriums den Fernsehturm von
Kiew hier auch die Bilder ja der Turm
der wurde bisher wohl noch nicht
getroffen wie es aus ersten Aufnahmen
hervorgeht aber er war wohl ziel dieses
Angriffs ja und nach den Bildern die wir
uns vorliegen die über Twitter
reinkommen die wir inzwischen
verifizieren konnten und die das
Innenministerium bestätigt er sieht es
aus als wenn es mehrere Angriffe gegeben
hat aber der Fernsehturm steht noch nach
diesen Bildern jedenfalls gehen wir
direkt nach Kiew zu unseren Reportern
Peter hell und Paul ronsheimer die uns
beide jetzt zugeschaltet sind Paul fange
mit dir an wie hast du diesen Angriff
erlebt was hast du davon mitbekommen
Thomas wir waren im Jahr mehrere
Kilometer davon entfernt muss man sagen
das liegt dieser
Fernsehturm liegt in der Nähe eines
gedenkzentrums für Holocaust
Opfer barbine ja das ist eine
Gedenkstätte ausgerechnet in dieser Nähe
wurde dieser Fernsehturm getroffen man
hat Einschläge gehört tatsächlich ist es
das worauf sich die Stadt seit heute
morgen seit heute Mittag vorbereitet
ursprünglich aber hatte man erwartet
dass Wladimir Putin zunächst ein
geheimdienstgebäude das
hauptgeheimdienstgebäude
bombardieren würde denn die SPU der
ukrainische Geheimdienst sollte Ziel
sein das war bekannt gegeben worden mit
dem Hinweis dass ich Zivilisten von dort
entfernen sollten jetzt der tv-turm das
ist der klassische Vorgehen der
russischen Armee zunächst einmal die
Möglichkeit zu nehmen in den
TV-Stationen weiterhin über das zu
berichten was wirklich passiert und dann
davon gehen alle aus wird man auch
versuchen sozusagen Handynetze und
Internet hier im anzugreifen und zu
stören um dann die Kommunikation mit den
Menschen außer Kraft zu setzen das ist
das Vorgehen der russischen Armee zu
beobachten auch in anderen Regionen
dieser Welt wir gehen davon aus dass das
heute der Start sein könnte eines großen
Angriffs hier auf die Hauptstadt gehen
wir weiter zu Peter hell Peter hast du
diesen Angriff auch miterlebt und was
kannst du sagen über die Auswirkungen
dieses Angriffs Handynetz habt ihr zum
Glück noch senden denn die
Fernsehstation weiterhin
bei mir war es genauso wie bei Paul es
ist sehr außerhalb wir haben das auch
erst extern erfahren die Handys gehen
noch alle bei uns das TV der Sender der
ukrainische Sender ist eingestellt die
anderen funktionieren noch die sind
nicht betroffen aber was eben im Vorfeld
auch
gewarnt worden ist seitens der Russen
das eben telekommunikative oder
einrichtungsgebäude die telekonomie
Telekommunikation beinhalten angegriffen
werden da haben sie angeblich immerhin
schon gewarnt dass wenn Zivilisten dort
in der Nähe sind dass dort evakuiert
werden soll dann wurde auch gewarnt dass
ein sogenanntes
infopsychologisches Zentrum des
ukrainischen Geheimdienstes bombardiert
werden sollte also man versucht jetzt
ganz klar die
Kommunikationsschnittstelle der
ukrainischen Armee und der Bevölkerung
zu durchbrechen das ist das erste in
einer Kriegsführung psychologischen
Kriegsführung auch taktisch dass ich
eben die Kommunikationswege
zerstöre das heißt ich will unterbinden
dass eben mein Gegner hier auf dem Grund
weiß was der andere macht das heißt auf
deutsch gesagt was Paul richtig sagt es
geht los das ist erst der Anfang weil
danach kommen andere infrastrukturelle
andere militäre militärische Ziele
werden dann ins Visier genommen um dann
eben einen größeren Angriff einzuleiten
Paul der gerade kommt die Nachricht
herein über unsere Kanäle dass Vitali
Klitschko der Bürgermeister von Kiew auf
telegram bekannt gegeben hat der Feind
greift die Hauptstadt an das würde also
bedeuten dass es tatsächlich losgeht als
wir vorhin gesprochen haben hast du
gerade ich glaube es war Vladimir der
dich gerade angerufen hatte während wir
diese Schalter gemacht haben was kannst
Du dazu sagen
ja ich habe tatsächlich nervöse Stimmung
wahrgenommen beim Bürgermeister der
Stadt und auch Emotionen was gerade hier
in seiner Stadt die er seit 2014 regiert
kurz nach dem Mai darn zweimal im Amt
bestätigt miterlebt er organisiert vor
allem die zivilen und die Probleme die
dadurch entstehen durch die durch den
Krieg all die Versorgungslinien um die
er sich kümmern muss und natürlich war
das alles absehbar aber das zu erleben
als Bürgermeister das ist jetzt
tatsächlich losgeht dass man ins Zentrum
offenbar vorstoßen will das Wladimir
Putin nicht aufhört mit Bomben und
wahrscheinlich Luftangriffen das ist
etwas was man auch erst einmal verdauen
muss aber natürlich ist Vitali Klitschko
und die anderen die in Verantwortung
sind hier Kämpfer und die werden kämpfen
das hat er mehrfach angekündigt aber
natürlich ist das der Beginn auch einer
sehr krit Zeit für Vitali Klitschko wir
wissen dass er genauso wie silensky auf
Listen steht und wir wissen dass
Wladimir Putin in Tod sehen will
Peter noch mal kurze zurück zu dir ja
wir rüsten sich jetzt die Menschen für
diese sechste kriegsnacht in Folge die
entscheidende kriegsnacht ja sehr
wahrscheinlich also ja wie wird die
Verteidigung der Stadt aussehen wie wird
das organisiert
naja also eine Stadt wird dann meistens
über ein Verteidigungslinien eingeteilt
die äußere Linie die fängt dann meistens
bei den Brücken an da kann es sein dass
dort wahrscheinlich wenn es wirklich
hart auf hart kommt dann die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte einige Brücken
strenge sprengen um zu verhindern dass
russische Einheiten Bodeneinheiten
vorrücken können dann gibt es innere
Verteidigungslinien die natürlich mit
Road Blocks mit mit Stellung mit
ausgehobenen Stellungen hier in der
Stadt beginnen und dann gibt es den
sogenannten Partisanen Stellungskampf
das sind eben die
zigtausend Bürger die jetzt hier in Kiew
in der Innenstadt und in den
Außenbezirken quasi in ihren Wohnungen
in ihren versteckten getarnten
Stellungen mit ihren automatischen
Gewehren Panzerfäusten Sprengfallen
Molotowcocktails etc warten dass die
russische Armee hier einmarschiert und
wir glauben alle hier dass das die
schwierig die Prüfung sein wird und auch
das gefährlichste für die russische
Armee denn da ist nichts mehr mit
Technologie da ist auch nichts mehr mit
Digitalisierung das ist konventionelle
partisanenkriegsführung und da kann ein
sage ich mal zwei Euro Molotowcocktail
ein zwei bis fünf Millionen Dollar
Panzer zerstören das geht dann so
einfach also da stehen die Russen dann
quasi einer ganz hochmotivierten
Partisanen Armee Gegenüber die Hand in
Hand mit der regulären Armee kämpft und
das ist glaube ich das was die Russen am
meisten fürchten was jetzt beginnt ist
erstmal der äußere
Ring beziehungsweise jetzt die
Zerstörung der Kommunikation und dann
ist auch damit zu rechnen dass es zu
Luftschlägen kommt wahrscheinlich nicht
durch die Luftwaffe weil die Luftabwehr
der Ukrainer scheint ja noch zu
funktionieren die Russen haben auch noch
keinen Flughafen hier besetzen können
das heißt sie konnten auch noch kein
Brückenkopf hier bilden also das ist
eher ausgeschlossen wahrscheinlich dann
eher mit gezielten Schlägen durch
Marschflugkörper die dann in
entsprechenden
infrastrukturellen Gebäude
reingeschossen werden oder auch in
Stellung Paul wir bekommen gerade noch
mal über unsere Kanäle die Nachricht
herein dass Vitali Klitschko gesagt hat
der Turm der Fernsehturm sei beschädigt
worden und auch das daran liegende
Umspannwerk sei beschädigt worden so
dass also die Funktion dort
beeinträchtigt sind das in dem Moment wo
ebenfalls die Nachricht kommt dass der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz noch einmal
mit dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selensky telefoniert hat was bedeutet
das jetzt für selensky wenn tatsächlich
und vielleicht muss man ja mit weiteren
Angriffen rechnen damit der Fernsehturm
wirklich ausgeschaltet wird wenn sie
Lenski sich dann über Fernsehen
beispielsweise auch nicht mehr mit
seinen mutmach Reden ans Volk wenden
kann die ja jetzt so wichtig sind zum
Durchhalten
wenn einer anderen Kanäle gefunden hat
auf dieser Welt als Präsident dann ist
es würde mir selenski der fast in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen
ausschließlich für Social Media
kommuniziert hat das dann wieder weiter
getragen wurde in die Medien der sich
per Twitter per Facebook per Instagram
an die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
gewendet hat das ginge theoretisch noch
und für selenski wird es auch
wahrscheinlich weiter möglich sein denn
er hat Möglichkeiten dass er auch
weiterhin Netz hat natürlich als
Präsident und in seinem Umfeld
allerdings glaube ich ist das viel
größere Problem neben dem Fernsehturm
die Frage was passiert wenn das Internet
im Land ausfällt ich glaube das würde
dann bedeuten dass die Menschen eben
diese Mut machen messages von silensky
nicht mehr empfangen könnten er könnte
zwar senden aber die Menschen könnten es
nicht mehr empfangen und das könnte dann
zu großer Panik größer Verunsicherung
führen und das ist ja das was Russland
erreichen will hier was Wladimir Putin
erreichen will will Panik erreichen er
will dafür sorgen dass die Menschen
Angst kriegen dass sie zweifeln auch und
dann will er hier reingehen und am Ende
dafür sorgen dass sein Schreckens Regime
eine
Marionettenregierung hier installiert
wird das ist auch das muss einmal hier
zur Seite schauen das ist auch das was
in den geheimdienstberichten ja immer
wieder genannt wurde sein ursprünglicher
Plan war ein schneller Krieg mit
möglichst wenig zivilen Opfern und dann
die Installierung einer
Marionettenregierung der Haken peter
hatte schon angesprochen ist die große
der große Widerstand den man jetzt in
der Form noch gar nicht sehen kann aber
wir können ihn fühlen weil wir dort die
Menschen sehen mit den Waffen in den
Straßen peter hat heute beeindruckende
Bilder gefilmt wie Menschen dort Waffen
verteilt haben wie immer noch neue
Waffen reinkommen das ist das was wir es
dann sehen werden wenn russische
Soldaten in der Stadt sind und das wird
ganz anders aussehen als in den anderen
Städten in der Ukraine wo wir gesehen
haben wie Panzer reingefahren sind das
standen und zwar hunderte Ukrainer sehr
sehr mutig und haben gegen den
russischen Einmarsch protestiert aber in
diesem Dörfern Städten da wurden jetzt
nicht großflächig Waffen verteilt der
Krieg der Kampf und die Frage wer diesen
Krieg gewinnt konzentriert sich auf Kiew
das ist das Symbol das ist die
Hauptstadt hier wird alles entschieden
jetzt haben wir ja den ganzen Tag über
diese Bilder verfolgt von diesem
ellenlangen Convoi 64 km lang der sich
auf den Weg gemacht hat in die
ukrainische Hauptstadt nach Kiew heißt
das im Umkehrschluss es geht jetzt los
bei euch dass dieser Konvoi jetzt
angekommen ist
Peter ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
du darfst auch gerne antworten
okay ich gehe davon aus dass dieser
Konvoi
gar nicht so diese entscheidende Rolle
momentan spielt das ist natürlich
beängstigend und das
ängstigt auch die Menschen natürlich in
der Ukraine wenn man diesen 60 Kilometer
Konvois sieht aber es geht vor allem
momentan um den Beschuss des tv-turms
der
Stromversorgung des Internets und das
passiert mit Raketen das passiert
sozusagen mit
zielgerichteten Einschlägen und die
Frage des Konvois wird erst dann eine
Rolle spielen wenn du Wladimir Putin das
ganz große Raketen Besteck sozusagen
ausgeholt hat und hier schon einiges
zerstört hat erst dann würden
Bodentruppen hier reinkommen
es wird dunkel hinter euch Peter dieser
Angriff auf den Fernsehturm und die
Gefahr das Internet lahm zu legen was
bedeutet das für eure Arbeit
naja wir können so lange arbeiten wie
auch die Kommunikation funktioniert das
heißt wenn wir auch abgeschnitten werden
das heißt wir hätten kein Internet dann
sieht es auch dunkel aus wir haben dann
auch keinen Zugriff mehr auf Quellen das
ist dann analog natürlich alles was
natürlich nicht was eingeschränkt wird
weil wir auch eine Ausgangssperre haben
also unser Bewegungsraum ist relativ
eingeschränkt dann ab 8 Uhr ist schon
wieder ist schon wieder Ende wir dürfen
nicht auf die Straße bis 7 Uhr morgens
und das wird dann halt sehr schwierig
wir haben natürlich noch
Satellitentelefone etc aber das ist
natürlich auch Sinn und Zweck dann für
eine psychologische Kriegsführung was
die Russen erreichen wollen das einzige
was sie nicht haben möchten ist sind
Bilder Bilder die der Wahrheit
entsprechen und dass die dann noch in
die Welt hinaus getragen werden dass ist
das allerschlimmste für Sie das hält sie
allerdings nicht davon ab weiterzumachen
und
solange wir senden können und der Film
können wenn wir das natürlich machen
Peter hell und Paul ronsheimer in Kiel
vielen Dank an euch beide ja es gibt
breaking news denn es gibt tatsächlich
fünf Tote und fünf verletzte bei diesem
Angriff auf den Fernsehturm in Kiew das
meldet zumindest die Kiefer statt
Verwaltung wir sehen die Bilder unten
noch einmal vor gut einer Stunde ein
Angriff auf den Fernsehturm in Kiew das
ist ein strategisches Ziel natürlich um
die Kommunikation auszuschalten in Kiew
in der Hauptstadt dort und es ist kein
guter Vorbote für das was heute noch
bevorsteht